I feel like ever as these friends had
tagged my friends and I we have video
games which is like tag but a lot less
exhausting so tag is a movie that I
guess is based on the true story of a
bunch of friends who have been playing
the same game of tag for decades it's
like thirty years or something like that
they're all grown up one of them is
getting married he's never been tagged
he's played by Jeremy Renner so they all
get together like this is gonna be the
year we tag him he is going to be it so
that's the game they'll collaborate to
tag this guy for the first time in his
life at least during the game of tag
it's not like they play this all year
round it's just for the month of May my
birthday month which I understand pretty
good month magical things happen in May
more magical things probably happened
nine months before May but you know this
movie actually cracked me up just seeing
friends get together to play this game
that keeps them together I just love
seeing it because I'm starting to get to
that age where you realize they're oh my
god everyone grows up like ten years ago
I would always be like why do you need a
game to keep each other together I don't
understand watching this movie I'm a
current mind frame like current age my
current mindset I totally get it like
all my friends they're all married it's
easy for the continental drift of
friendship to happen much more rapidly
then a continental drift actually does
happen I found the story very sweet and
actually very smart good efficient way
to keep everyone in touch and I like
anything that allows Jon Hamm to flex
his comedic muscles I know him as this
serious dude this serious actor I know
he has comedy in him because I've seen
him do some fun and stuff we all have I
just like it when he has the opportunity
ed Helms placed an Ed Helms his
character he's pretty much the optimist
a guys we got to do this but he does it
as Ed Helms does in Ed Helms role Jake
Johnson plays the one who represents
what happens to most people who reach
that age Hannibal Buress is a Hannibal
Buress or Hannibal Buress I don't know
but you lined them all up and there's
such an array of personalities and
career paths life paths in general you
got the really successful guy you got
the burn out and you have everyone in
between you think to yourself maybe it's
not realistic that they're all friends I
feel like anyone who's been friends this
long they would have something in common
is you didn't feel like these guys had
anything in common you realize it's kind
of the point of the movie the game of
tag keeps them linked they do address
this in the movie but at a point you do
get some pause and you're like you
aren't the groomsmen in his wedding nor
did you get invites how close are you if
the game of tag is the only reason
they're friends
that kind of saddens me jeremy renner
has the least amount of screen time
because he is the point of the game for
this movie he's like the king in chess
he's not out there doing the most stuff
on the battlefield but he is the most
important piece he's the target they
need to get him they get him they went
when Renner was mentally breaking down
the scenario and you hear the voice over
slight smell of POD he's coming from
behind I'm gonna throw my coffee in his
face everything slows down and for the
most part that's what this movie is
scheming planning attempts at execution
and failure at that sit back and enjoy
yourself have a good time hey do you
have a moment in here to really hammer
home the drama and I don't feel they did
trying doesn't get so big play to say if
I get the bit in the end tags a very
enjoyable movie with a sweet premise to
it you and your friends you're gonna
grow up you're gonna age you're gonna
get separate lives so find something to
have a link between you all I think it's
a very important message I'm gonna sound
like an old guy in 3 2 1
especially in this day and age I will
say tag is a good time no alcohol
required right so tag have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's
your favorite movie about friendship
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]